true social might be going the way of
the dodo true social is Trump's
alternative to Twitter and uh truth
social
was begun back in October of 2021 and
now it might collapse within days and it
might collapse because
Trump media and Technology Group which
is the parent company for True social
was going to merge with digital world
acquisition corporation which is a
miami-based company
and they they were then going to go
public via a SPAC a SPAC is a special
purpose acquisition company and anyway
this is all sort of bunch of background
business blah blah blah but the upshot
is the two companies had between 12 and
18 months to complete the merger the
deadline has been extended at least five
times it's now scheduled for September
5th
shareholder meeting is scheduled I
suspect Trump doesn't want to keep true
social around anymore because I think
Trump wants to go back to Twitter now
known as X because that's the way that
he's going to reach the most people but
what happens then what happens if truth
social collapses is this good for Trump
is this bad for Trump
I think basically it would be good for
Trump and I think it would be good for
Trump because one he can now save face
since Elon bought Twitter
the point of Truth social was to give
conservatives an alternative in social
media the libs controlled all of social
media so here's an alternative well then
Elon Musk spent 44 billion bucks and
bought Twitter and has made Twitter much
more amenable to conservatives and has
defended the right of conservatives to
speak on Twitter and is now potentially
even suing left-wing activist groups
that are trying to to pressure
advertisers to defund Twitter you know
he's really put his money where our
mouths are so Trump can say face and say
look the thing that I wanted to
accomplish with fruit social has now
been accomplished through Elon Musk so
I'm going back
to Twitter I mean the the basic reason
that Trump started true social was that
he was de-platformed he was kicked off
of all these Services even when he was
the sitting president of the United
States well now he's been invited back
on and that is largely thanks to Elon
Musk so he can say look mission
accomplished right but what about the
the
black mark on his record here
Trump is going to be called a failure
because truth social was a failure
I don't think that matters and I
especially don't think that matters to
Trump
Trump has failed at many many things and
I say this with love and admiration he
failed at the Vodka he failed at the
stakes he failed at the airplanes he he
failed it a lot man I'm not even getting
into what happened when he was president
Trump is also one of the most successful
people on planet Earth
that's undeniable I know the Trump
haters want to deny that this man is
extremely successful if you fly around
in a gigantic jumbo jet for your entire
adult life you're a success if you get
yourself elected president the first
time that you really officially try it
you're a big success if you manage to
arouse the ire of America's enemies
abroad and the enemies within the the
Deep State apparatchics who consistently
tried to undermine his campaign in his
presidency you're a success man you've
actually done something are these in
opposition no not at all
the most successful people I know
have also failed more than just about
anybody I know
and it's this is a really important
lesson if you ever want to succeed in
life
successful people tend to fail at more
things than their critics ever even try
and pride which is the queen of vice and
the deadliest of the seven deadly sins
Pride talks in our ear and says hey
don't do this thing you might fail at it
so don't even try just it'll be so
humiliating if you it'll be such a wound
to your pride if you if you try and fail
at something
successful people just ignore that voice
and just try things and they often will
throw spaghetti at the wall think about
how many
how many companies Trump has failed at
or Elon Musk has failed at or
I don't know any of the successful
people on planet Earth
if you go military leaders the failed
military campaigns for goodness sakes
Winston Churchill had he died before the
second world war would have died a
colossal failure but he just kept going
this is true of every great Statesman
throughout history and business leader
and just anybody who's ever done
anything
a really important lesson to take away
it's one of the best lessons from
Trump's public life and look maybe he's
going to fail in the 2024 race I don't
know but the one thing I'm damn sure of
is that he's gonna try and the only way
that he's possibly going to be
successful the only way that you or any
of us is possibly going to be successful
at anything is if we risk failure don't
don't worry about failure
successful people are going to fail more
than than the losers ever even tried
right now go to goodranches.com use code
nulls I don't know about you but this
summer heat in Nashville felt hotter
than a two dollar pistol and that's
because of the inflation we're feeling
that heat in more ways than one these
days the thing that I'm not sweating
though is my meat price thanks to good
ranchers my price is locked in for two
years and you might be thinking a price
lot guarantee on meat yeah it's amazing
I don't know how they do it it doesn't
make any sense with inflation and
everything and especially that their
price is already quite low for meat that
is much higher quality than anything
you're getting at the grocery store or
any other service right now it's just
the greatest their hamburgers are the
best I've ever had the steaks are
absolutely out of this world the New
York strip in particular I love the rib
eye is excellent I just had the other
day they've got pork now they've got
chicken they've got everything I
couldn't possibly recommend this company
enough their meat is all 100 American
Steakhouse quality just amazing
goodranchers.com right now use code
Knowles for 30 bucks off any box promo
code Knowles Canada wlas goodranches.com
goodranchors.com American Meat delivered
a DC grocery store
Giant grocery store is southeast DC has
removed name brands
from the store it's got generic brands
but no more name brands Advil Colgate
tied it's gone
it's gone because people keep stealing
and the shop owner he says I don't want
to do this I'd like to sell the name
brand products but the reality is that
tide is not a profitable item in this
store because it keeps getting stolen in
many instances people stock the product
and within two hours it's gone so it's
not on the Shelf anyway
you see he's seen theft rise tenfold in
the last five years
this is
literally why we can't have nice things
just even material things we can't have
we sell out all of the Social Capital so
that we can have cheap consumer goods
and the irony of it is we end up without
even the nice consumer goods
because people are stealing so much that
they can't even put them on the shelves
if we cease to be a coherent society as
increasingly is happening and we simply
become individual economic units just
sharing the same space which is the
vision the left has for us and frankly
it's the vision that a lot of the right
has for us too we're just out there we
just care about cutting our taxes and
just making our money and leave me alone
and forget about those social questions
well okay if we're all just individuals
living in the same space then you know
what's going to happen
all the things that keep us behaving
Community shame a sense of a fear of
divine retribution concern for our souls
and our reputation in the community even
the law that's all going to go away and
so what's going to happen is first
there's going to be disorder as we're
seeing now and then almost maybe even
worse than the disorder
there's going to be a miserable kind of
order imposed on us
because this is the point I've made a
number of times before there will be
order
there will be order
the state
will protect itself
so either we can behave ourselves
and act in accordance with virtue and
religion and morality or the state is
going to come in and impose that
but there there will be order eventually
and the the kind of order that's going
to be imposed on us
is going to be a miserable one
because it's going to be a an order
without
the uplift and the inspiration of
religion without the natural bonds of
family which disappear I mean they
disappear in the sense that people just
stop having family they stop getting
married they stop having kids it's going
to be one without tradition we'll have
gotten rid of those Traditions it's
going to be one without a sense of
loyalty to the nation and a bond of
kinship to the people it's just going to
be
a heavy-handed order
of
it of sticks and carrots the stick is
going to be increasing punishments from
the government like locking people up
for ordinary basic political dissent as
we're seeing all around us and the
carrot is going to be drugs and
promiscuous sex and
Netflix and
staying out late and drinking and going
to Beyonce concerts and not getting out
of your bed until 10 in the morning
that's
that one of them is George Orwell one of
them is Aldous Huxley one of them is
1984 one of them is Brave New World and
it's not going to be one of the other
you're going to get them both at the
same time do you want do you want that
to be your Society no
well then
we've got to have the other stuff the
tradition and the coherence among the
people
and the religion and the
end of being normal
and that's what we're going to have to
have boy what a great clip that was now
make sure that you ring the bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel see you next time